des tomates en quantité et une maturité
très précoce en lien avec la météo
caniculaire c'est ce qui explique le
phénomène de surproduction constaté chez
des maraîchers de notre région
l'exploitation la racine riz à
Saint-Cyr-en-Val a même renoncé à la
cueillette en attendant de pouvoir
transformer ses tomates en conserve sur
la tomate avec les chaleurs précoces
qu'on a eu on a on est à peu près trois
semaines d'avance sur la production de
tomates on a de toute façon
classiquement l'effet vacances qui fait
qu'une majorité de notre clientèle est
absente sur juillet-août là on a quand
même une grosse baisse des ventes sur
les marchés on a l'effet covid qui fait
que le retour des vacances est assez
fort donc il y a beaucoup de tomates
elle est là maintenant la
commercialisation en vente directe et
difficile donc si on veut utiliser la
tomate et la valoriser c'est c'est
maintenant et la conserverie c'est
vraiment l'outil adapté tomate et
courgettes de l'exploitation mais aussi
d'autres producteurs régionaux sont
actuellement dans leur pic de production
des denrées qui prennent directement le
chemin de la conserverie pour y être
transformé en soupe c'est ça ou la benne
là on a vraiment une production qui est
en avance
intense et on est pas sûr qu'elle va
durer aussi tard que les autres années
on n'est pas sûr d'avoir de la tomate en
septembre en octobre et donc vraiment
tous bouscule en ce moment et nous c'est
des semaines très chargées pour
transformer nos légumes et pour en
sauver au maximum pour répondre au
maximum aux demandes de nos collègues en
avance sur le calendrier la conserverie
fonctionne à plein régime et évite un
gaspillage alimentaire même s'il sera
difficile d'absorber toute la
surproduction